[Music]
good evening everyone
and welcome to this evening's iai event
on designer babies nazi talk of a master
race
and the atrocities that it spawned have
led us to be appalled by the idea of
eugenics
and its proposed manipulation of human
reproduction to improve the species
yet 83 of women have prenatal tests
for abnormalities including down
syndrome
and if diagnosed the great majority then
choose to have terminations
meanwhile sperm banks allow the
selection of characteristics that
include
height eye color ethnicity
and intelligence are we hypocritical to
condemn past figures
such as churchill for sympathizing with
eugenics while applying eugenic
principles
in our personal lives should we regulate
prenatal tests terminations and sperm
banks
more tightly or should we extend further
our ability to precisely determine the
character
of our children and i'd now like to
introduce our four fantastic panelists
who are going to speak on these issues
first of all we have becky bennett
professor in bioethics at the university
of manchester
with almost 30 years of experience in
teaching bioethics
becky has published on a wide range of
issues but has special interest
in the ethics of screening for down
syndrome jacob appel
is a bioethicist author poet
psychiatrist
and social critic with seven masters
degrees
10 plays and 19 books jacob remains
proud of the 21 000 rejection letters
he has received over the years simon
baron cohen
is a cognitive neuroscientist and the
director of cambridge's autumn
autism research center who has argued
that autism involves
a disability in empathy alongside
strength in pattern recognition
his research has explored the prenatal
biology
of autism and finally we have kyrie
steffensen
who is the founder and ceo of decode
genetics
a company that controversially used the
medical records of the icelandic health
service
to create a database of the public's
medical genetic
and genealogical data pioneering
use of population scale genetics to
further understanding of variation
in the human genome are we inadvertently
sliding towards eugenics so
becky would you like to start us off
well traditional eugenics
involves the overriding of reproductive
choices
of individuals and it's usually based on
one powerful group's notion of the
ideal society overriding individuals
choices is problematic
if we want to live in a society that
values the ability to run our own lives
and overriding these choices based on
the subjective or unsubstantiated views
of what is considered to be the best
human being
is even more difficult to justify
eugenic policy sends a powerful
unjustified
negative message about certain groups in
society
but it's not clear that all the things
we're going to talk about this evening
can be compared to
to this kind of ethically offensive
eugenics some of the things we're
talking about here
are simply about allowing individuals
the freedom to make reproductive choices
however once there's pressure to choose
in a particular way then we move towards
many of the negative connotations
of traditional eugenics let's take
for example routine screening for down
syndrome
having a diagnostic test for down
syndroming pregnancy is not
ethically problematic in itself there
are all sorts of reasons why people will
want to know
if the fetus they are carrying has the
condition the problem comes in the way
that this test is offered
by making this part of routine screening
and making it part of a routine
screening program
we send a message that having this
screening test is a good idea and we
send a negative message
about living with down syndrome this
puts pressure on people
not only to accept the test but also
about what's considered to be the right
choice after receiving a positive test
result
before we consider these questions
further there's also
another very important distinction to
make
some of the choices we will make will
affect the welfare of the
of the same person and other decisions
will affect who will be born
unlike same person choices preventing
the birth of a child
with a condition seen as disabling does
not
improve this child's welfare they can
either be born
with this condition or not be born at
all what it does mean is that somebody
else will be born instead and
for me this is a really important
distinction when it comes to the ethics
of these issues
so given that identifying what is the
best life is impossible
we should try and enable individuals to
have as free of reproductive choices as
possible
based on balanced unbiased information
allowing the state to override or even
influence the reproductive choices
of individuals is not justified and
actually does the opposite of creating
the sort of society we wish to live in
it creates a world where only the choice
is that the powerful
agree with are upheld thank you for
sharing your thoughts on this theme so
i'd like to pass
to jacob please thank you so my sense is
that
everyone on the zoom call wants to make
the world a better
place we just have different senses of
how to do it
as a libertarian myself i think there's
been much too much
emphasis on the libertarian aspects of
the debates surrounding designer babies
because then you get concerned of the
world drifting towards something
what i'd like to do is emphasize a few
points about the communitarian and
egalitarian
benefits of designing babies that may
make an argument for running toward it
rather than being concerned that we're
drifting toward it first
designer babies hold the promise of
making the world better
even for those who wish you the practice
imagine
if rather than a newton or an einstein
every century
we had many of them in every generation
how many diseases might we cure with
this knowledge
how many insoluble scientific or social
problems
might we fix however much shakespeare or
edison
might benefit from their own
accomplishments the rest of us benefit
too
and the math sends a rising tide raises
all ships
second designer babies hold the promise
of creating a more equitable society
this may seem counterintuitive to a lot
of people but at present
we already grant considerable advantage
to those who are well-heeled
um if you can hire an academic tutor you
can get into a fenced university
if you can hire a tennis coach for your
kids they can play at wimbledon
um and that compounds underlying
biological injustices
my sense is that everyone on this call
has
a rather significant gift of
intelligence having worked with patients
whose iqs are in the 75 to 80 range the
world is much harder for them
we should make it easier but that's also
a significant burden to bear
if we lived in a remotely equitable
world
where there were any promise of us
reaching that point sometime
soon there might be a compelling
argument for limiting
these sorts of reproductive
interventions but we don't
and with that in mind designer babies
may be the best opportunity we have to
create business equality they might be
the great equalizer
so my goal with the underlying premise
that these are inevitable
if you look at what happened in china
with germline editing
eventually somebody will begin designing
babies in the way that i am talking
about
we want to make sure that resources are
devoted to making everyone have an equal
opportunity
and to making sure that the people who
don't reveal themselves this opportunity
have their rights protected
thanks thank you jacob yes a very
compelling argument there so um
uh simon would you like to share your
thoughts on this theme
um so i want to pick up on on becky's
um topic of of down syndrome
and just to register my concern
about jacob's argument but we'll come
back to that
um so if we think about the screening
for down syndrome
the test that was widely used for most
of
the last century was amniocentesis
and it actually goes back to the 1930s
but by the time amniocentesis could be
done
with ultrasound so that you could guide
the needle
uh into the womb um in about the 1970s
it then became widespread practice and
you know from the 1980s onwards it's
been offered as a test for down syndrome
i'm not aware that there was a national
or an international debate
on the ethics of introducing this
technology
in terms of what are we doing to our
population
um i'm sure carrie is going to pick this
up after me
but in iceland where he's from the
uh uptake of amniocentesis is near
universal
so the result in iceland is that 99
of people with down syndrome who would
have lived
were terminated or prevented from living
meaning that there are only one or two
people with down syndrome
who are born every year in the whole
country so the question are we
inadvertently sliding towards
eugenics i think it's already happened
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
you